Dustin hears this here daltin is one of
my favorite people you have this magnet
of hilarious stories that just happened
to you and around you was it New Year's
that like your car almost like exploded
or something it was Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving was a holiday it makes it
more interesting in a mountain during a
snowstorm Johnson just got a new car as
three weeks old
it's insane of a security system that
was put in
yeah but the warning on the screen was
like park this car in a safe place
immediately and call for help
and I was like it goodness is it gonna
blow up like what happened I don't even
know the cars could have that as an
emergency warning inside of them like
please exit your vehicle we are going to
explode get that yeah
how are your dogs my dogs are you know
the light of my life
hey Callen is two dogs I love dogs
one's a dog one the jury's out on yeah
well I'm a space creature yeah you have
a dog named Jones and is a Boston
Terrier yes and then a dog named nugget
that looks like you put Jones in a dryer
and took him out and created this dog
look yeah but nugget also has human
eyeballs he's like this little freak
that runs around with like no care or
worries but also like looks very human
in the face yes he's got an underbite
his teeth are all janky he's like you
know he's a rescue dog and he like it
just emotes rescue yeah he's just like
help me he's the sweetest it's my
favorite thing on your snapchat it's
just when Nuggets being like a complete
like unconscious weirdo yes being
himself he has no idea how bizarre he is
right everything right so like just for
a little taste like what sums up this
dog is I take him to this in front of
the school but my house to run because I
don't really have a yard he wanted to
run so badly but I didn't anything that
for him to we're like that's throwing a
palm frond
yes watching it he was so happy yeah so
then I found like a little lime or
something uh-huh so he started catching
this lime I'm going after this lime and
then I turned around at one point it he
had eaten the whole thing is just like
Hey he wasn't even enjoying it like
there's no way he likes me alive he
wanted to kill it he wanted to destroy
it that's somebody like dog I buzz
because like there's absolutely no
enjoyment there's no way that tasted
good deal but you just committed to it I
wouldn't help himself he's like and if
you see this dog it literally is like
animal from the Muppets that just flops
around without a care in the world and
just like joseline to save him and
protect him from himself yeah and it's
so funny especially cuz Jones your other
dog would not give less of a [ __ ] about
nugget at all but it also be like Jones
sleeping like this old man dog sleeping
so calm and the Nugget just comes in
from like a frame out of nowhere and
just like slams headfirst just like I'm
here now very weird cuz he's uh he
dominates Jones Jones lets him Jones is
like I don't care no ego at all but he's
not like aggressive he doesn't have a no
ounce of aggression in him so checking
the park and he'll roll with these big
dogs yeah I am and they'll try to be
aggressive with him and he'll turn out
like so thank you isn't you've ever seen
oh yeah you go to the dog park all the
time with them I have to run him because
he's insane he's so high energy he is so
over-the-top have you had any uh
ridiculous stories with him it's because
I feel like every time I see on your
snapchat him at the dog park he's
literally just found a puddle and it's
just flopping himself in the smallest
puddle he could [ __ ] yeah
mud clings to him yeah it actually
clings to his first he finds mud
wherever we are
uh-huh he is truly like I always calm a
trash dog like I just imagined when he
was born and he just like walked out of
like a Oscar the Grouch style yeah and
we have fish skeleton on his back like a
coffee filter on his head like to the
side like a real gentleman was
ridiculous
yeah took the dog park once and I
couldn't find him and I'm like where is
yet I hear this Yelp and I look over and
and he's like next to this dog so I walk
over and this little girls like our dogs
are stuck together I was like what
she's like the dogs are stuck together
in the pic she's she's maybe eight her
parents are there and they're like it's
okay sweetie don't touch them and and so
the bit nugget is stuck to this dog and
I I'm like what is it said I'm googling
and I'm madly googling I go I'm like
what how could it be struck together
what's going on and and I'm texting my
friends and so finally I okay oh they
these dogs had text oh my precious child
my sweet baby boy stuck it to this
little [ __ ] dog ah may I say that oh my
and what happens is there's like a
system yeah then they're stuck together
until their stuff stops swelling Oh like
20 minutes of dogs being stuck together
oh well the best part is at me and his
eight-year-old were in the same place of
knowledge where we both didn't
understand and the parents were like uh
ma'am it's um it's fine like they
couldn't say in front of her what was
actually happening are you in this eight
you're older just like what's going on
like this doesn't make any sense way
they're stuck together us so sad and
then my friend Becky takes me back and
she goes yeah that's called blank or
whatever it was and she's like how do
you not know that Oh weird oh I had no
idea she called me a weirdo and I was
like you want to know what's weird
knowing about dog Sestak happily I am so
happy I'm so glad I do not know about
this what must have been incredible is
then having to sit there while they're
stuck together I just pretend that it's
not happening for them to get unstuck
my sweet baby boy I just can't look at
him the same ever I go my job's done yet
you're tainted how long did it take for
them at least 15 minutes oh my god he
was so gross dude that's so
uncomfortable wet and your publicly at a
dog park just outside
you can't like pick them up and like
let's take this inside somewhere
away from everyone they're like but -
but what about their names incredibly
painful yeah and also uh so weird to see
as another person at the dog park just
kind of looking at looks I mean I hope
he learned his lesson but he's the kind
of dog that I feel like doesn't learn
anything just constantly is like
Groundhog Day like wow yeah yeah yeah I
feel like Nugget lives a brand-new life
every minute day he totally does and my
older dog is just like what are you so
stay away from me
that Jones is the best I have this stuff
that I'm obsessed with which is um
liquid gold leaf it's made of cancer it
smells like pure dad just dropped and
just splashed everywhere it was just
like not a good kind of not getting a
happy accident